they were looking at the research that has demonstrated that in this election
young men are increasingly leaning right
while young women are increasingly leaning left
and how young men but not young women
are gravitating towards religion
and they were like oh
why could this be like
I'll give you a hint
it rhymes with
schmishogony
then they interview a lot of these
young men and women to learn more about like
tell us about your politics
what issues are important to you
and they draw out that one of the key themes amongst these young men
meanwhile the women were like
I'm really worried about sexism
I'm worried about the rhetoric
I'm worried about them taking away my rights
I'm worried about my health care
and the episode
treated these like these were two separate things
they were like well
the young women are really concerned about sexism
and young men today just don't really know their place
and their longing for traditional values
since when have we rebranded misogyny as traditional values
these young men were pretty blatantly like
I want a woman to stay home like the good old days
does no one know anything about history
why women needed to be with men
why all women were in the home
why all of them were doing unpaid domestic labor
I'm not at all knocking stay at home parents
but they weren't saying
we should have an economy where one of the parents can stay home
they were all very specific about how that person should be a woman
and how JD Vance
and Trump are running this traditional values campaign that really values that
it's like it it's just misogyny???
literally saying on the one hand
we wanna force women to do reproductive labor against their will
and also we're really longing for that time when all women were in the home